the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to day five
of the 2022 fall chess classic we've had
a lot of exciting action so far uh and
we're going to be getting right back
into it my name is Jonathan schonce and
I'm happy to be joined here with Grand
Master Miro yeah well happy to be here
Jonathan and yeah well it's a little bit
ahead of a schedule but just to mention
that we not only watch the chat but
interact with the chat absolutely uh
someone said cool animations we actually
are not animated we are physically
present in the studio just to let you
know absolutely and some people would be
taking a rest right now but not us
Sunday it's a day of rest for some but
this tournament has no rest days and
we're going to be here covering all the
action for you live and let's actually
go ahead and see how everybody's been
doing starting with our standings for
the a group now in the a group we do
have a soul leader and it is vidit he is
sitting there on three points all by
himself right underneath him we have
ilianize Nick Gregory o'parin and Von
Nguyen a half Point behind with two and
total then after that Yu Yang Yi and
Hans Neiman are sitting on two points
below that we got nijaj absoff Aram
hakobian Surya Ganguly and Nicholas
theodoro Miro could you please let us
know what is going on in Group B uh well
Group B round Knox adwani was held for a
draw yesterday but still in the lead and
yeah I think the top has not changed
much right so all three oh well now I'm
paying attention uh round four all draws
it does absolutely exactly when we left
every single game was going on every
single game was a draw so the students
are pretty much as you would expect
nothing has changed so it's right knock
sadwani then it died for the second
these are Christopher you and Alex
landerman both representing U.S Dennis
coverage on clears fourth position well
something has changed for sure Armand
michaelan finally was able to put
something on the board yep so everyone
is on the board now and let's get to
know our tournament starting with the
tournament formats now this is two 10
player round Robins we got the a group
in the B group there is 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves at move 40 you
receive an additional 30 minutes for the
rest of the game and all throughout the
tournaments you get a 30 second
increments uh now Miro if you could just
let us know what is the schedule of
events for the rest of this event yeah
well let's update on the schedule no
major updates here so starting from
Fifth and all the all the way to the
next round everything starts 1pm as the
previous rounds have started except for
November 10th when we do start a couple
of hours earlier please start a couple
earlier our show will start a couple
hours earlier because of possible
playoffs those will be necessary just to
remind everybody we are starting our
90-minute show three hours after the
start time that you see there so when it
says 1pm the show actually starts 4 P.M
central time so keep that in mind if
you're looking to catch the show with
all of that in out of the way I just
would like to say thank you guys for
being here and watching every single day
it's been a lot of fun we're live on
Twitch we're live on YouTube we're
reading all of the chat that you guys
are sending in and if you guys do want
to follow us on social media please make
sure to use the hashtag fall chess
classic you can also catch all of the
games live on
uschesschamps.org and also just a little
bit of a reminder that this is your
money is going to a very good place any
money that we do receive via YouTube or
via twitch it is all go going to support
the Scholastic initiative that we have
here at the St Louis chess club so for
every 75 dollars that we raise whether
it's through YouTube head revenue or
whether it's through bits subscriptions
donations anything that goes on Twitch
it's all going to uh to give kids a
school program so every 75 dollars is
one entire program an entire semester
for a kid that might otherwise not be
able to receive it uh with all of that
it being said I also want to take a look
now at our pairings for today starting
with the a group now in the a group
Nicholas theodoro is going up against
Gregory o'parin Aaron Jacobian is going
up against Soria Ganguly you Yang Yi is
playing against Ilia niznik Von Nguyen
is playing vidit and our matchup of the
day is ninjat absof going up against
Hans Neiman who is still sitting Miro on
four draws overall yeah so someone's
gonna break this Rick today because
ninja has well assured but very
unpleasant streak of two losses in the
row while Hans is on four drills out of
four rounds so it doesn't matter how
those two will play today someone's
going to be yeah okay
whose streak is gonna break yeah yeah
yeah of course had started the
tournament very strong winning in like
21 moves it was you know one of these
like opening disasters for his opponent
got off to a very early lead but the
last two rounds have not treated them
very well what is happening in this game
that we got today uh yeah so that's uh
that's a current position where
um yeah it's white to move after Hans
just played Knight C4 to E5 and we could
probably check what the opening was but
once again we are turning in after three
hours everything's very
uh culture heavy everything's equal you
know symmetrical Pawn structure well
yeah we are talking like minimal wages
like plus zero two minus is there
anything to be said for having two
Bishops or is it yes yeah but you you'd
expect once again something really wild
or I would expect no no such thing all
right well how did all this happen yeah
so it was with some if transposition it
happened to be a Catalan with Bishop B4
check and back to E7 so this loss of
tempo quote unquote loss of tempo is
very popular I think for like 15 years
already like someone figured out that
you can actually play a check return
back and pretend that you are beginner
so you've lost the tempo well there is a
certain point to it once again so very
often white would play D3 Bishop B2 and
it's hard to play Bishop B2 when your
Bishop D2 right it's a queen to C2 C6
Rook C1 and that's one of the attempts
um to kind of prove that Bishop D2 is
worth something because very often white
would just neglect the fact that he is
tempo apko Bishop D2 to F4 and then we
have the same position just with one
more move play right mirror if you'd
allow it so in round one we also saw
somebody playing the Catalan against
Hans that resulted in a draw yeah do you
think this I mean it might just be a
coincidence maybe two people play the
Catalan that could obviously be true but
you think people are trying to like
specifically test his Catalan skills as
black if they targeted this as a
weakness or something so not really I
mean it's not uh say it's not a lot of
choices you have against what Hans plays
right so Knight F6 E6 and I'm if I'm
allowed to go back to speculate a little
kind of Rights uh before Knight F6 C4 E6
uh yeah if you start the game with these
two now uh against D5 you pretty much
have two serious options it's Queen's
Gambit or the catalans right and here in
order to play the real real Queen's
Gambit right uh you want to go Knight C3
D5 and this can be something right with
uh Knight still being on G1 and
potential Knight G2 those systems right
we've seen Hans playing the nimzo so
maybe that's what people are avoiding
exactly and there was one game against
one Norwegian Magnus Carlson yeah has
happened it went very well for hunt so
I'm not saying that he kind of refuted 3
Knight C3 right but maybe that's what
people are trying yeah people kind of
don't have interest in playing this and
you can still of course go Knight C3 or
even like delay the knights development
go to G5 but that's uh well that's known
as relatively harmless yeah relatively
harmless uh Queen's Gambit so therefore
perhaps G3
and okay anyway catalan's quite popular
I'm not sure about this specific line a
five um
yeah just checking yeah I wanted to say
it's a bit of a sideline but it was
played by no one else but Magnus cousin
himself okay so bad against Daniel dubov
so e2e3 and that's yeah okay now we no
longer have
no longer have Constance games but we
have giri who played it in December last
year so E3 was still happened B5 all
that happened in the game between uh
giri and volocadian where giri played
something else A3 sort of sort of an
independent move a force basically what
happens here so white
tries to claim control over the C file
is somewhat better perhaps somewhat more
harmonious development but potentially
if black ever gets the Knight on C4
which will he will in our game that
black is more than fine so Knight to D6
Bishop to A6 a bit awkward but you need
to protect the B5 pawn and then the
knight's gonna go to sleep Bishop D3
g6h4 okay that's something Knight C4
Queen E2 Rook C8 Knight A2 that's a
funny move yes Knight A2 to B4 right
black girls Knight B8 E4 okay okay
Knight back to D7 Knight before Queen B6
and this is how white got a pair of
Bishops
but still the Knight on 4 is quite nice
and yeah later on black was able to play
E5
and then perhaps
D5 Knight C5 doesn't look all that
attractive who knows maybe a black will
be you know will be even better one day
sure neither the six back is not that
great because Rook C6 yeah but Knight C5
perhaps yeah so why decided to Simply
trade on A5 and this now we got a
completely symmetrical Pond structure
yeah it can be something but it cannot
be too much for sure that that's what I
would say between F6 and the queens were
traded and white went Bishop C3 here to
be perfectly honest I thought Bishop C3
Rook takes
C3 rookie 2 should be enough for a draw
because
yeah
and you probably end up being down upon
in a rook end game uh captures captures
captures on B2 white takes but that's
not the hard uh
not a hard Rook end game to make a drone
I think you're even allowed to go H5
here just not to care about the space on
the on the king side sure because with
with behind it's a kind of an easy draw
so white can try to do something like
Rook F4 and A4 with Rook on the side but
still it serves like it's theoretical
for this kind of players it shouldn't be
a problem sure but yeah why to play a
position Pawn down if you can play the
position with even number of Pawns
that's what Hans decided he went Knight
E5 white has played Bishop A5 all right
so this way he tries to exchange a pair
of Rooks maybe invaded on the seventh
ring yeah it could be something in the
long run yeah it could be something okay
so not a whole lot but we need to see uh
what is happening here if anything a
very small Advantage for white and uh
just to catch everybody up too we also
have a b group so let's go ahead and
take a look at our games today in the B
group uh yeah let's find out so akshat
Chandra against armaniquelian Dennis
with Christopher Ryu and yeah as I keep
saying I'm looking forward to those
Christopher interviews but he has to win
for that right Alex Lenderman faces
tigrant harutinyan gegali Contour goes
against Brandon Jacobson and rodnack
sadhwani and Christian carrilla are
playing
or should I say already well we I hope
that they're not playing because I have
been seeing Christian carrilla in the
chat so shout out to uh our competitor
and fellow commentator Christian his
game has already concluded for the day
it did result in a draw so maybe we can
check this one out first and see exactly
what happened today yeah okay so that
that's once again another confirmation
that all Rook end games are true
that's the one that we had as the final
position
so here the e45 Knight F3 Knight F6 so
that was the Petrov that Christian has
played
and yeah it's hard to go wrong with the
patch of and what actually did try to
play something a bit more complex
because one of the moves is just a taken
D7 and then it's for a very long time
it's quite a symmetrical line sure so
why does this girl's Knight C3 if I'm
not mistaken yeah it was quite popular
on High level
95 93 so you get this kind of structure
so the white is white has the majority
on the king side and yeah kind of
somewhat more space but his pawns are
doubled on the queen side
once again Magnus Carlsen is on the list
of players who played it with the white
piece can't be too bad so you'd expect
yeah this one to be a serious line
Bishop C5 Queen to H5 kind of stopping
Black from casting at least for now
Bishop E6 Rook to B1 so basically white
wants to call some you know some
weaknesses like B6 okay you give me an
option to give a check on B5 right
Bishop B6 well maybe bishop A3 will
become a thing one day uh anyway black
chose to ignore it just gets Queen D7
and perhaps if you capture then Black
Goes Bishop B6 and try to pick the Rook
yeah traps The Rook later on so the pawn
wasn't captured Bishop G5 Bishop to F5
and black ignores the thread for quite a
while Queen F3 trade only 3C takes
castles D4
where like wow so black girls FC all
right some action yeah so in fact this
one considered by the weak engine that
we have here to be better for white a
wood White Castle short simply and after
D4 he perhaps was expecting like the
position yeah and F6 happens to be a
clever he'll have a move it takes then
it was a check King D2 because King F1
kind of breaks the connection between
the Rooks and I yeah
which allows you to win the pawn back
and also kind of keep the Integrity of
this truck this is because gf6 is still
awkward even though the materials this
looks really scary for white I mean yeah
you're losing a lot
2 Rook HD1 Bishop F6 so trade straight
and yeah it does give the computer tends
to like black just a tiny bit more Queen
E3 Rook A6 and then he went to trading
these Queens yeah to trade the stuff
we've given drug C8 so he ends up I
wanted to say Pawn down not really okay
black has the past Pawn but but that's
about it yeah yeah interesting all right
so it was a little bit of action there
it got exciting for just a moment but it
all worked itself out to a draw in the
end so yeah uh very good let's go ahead
and just kind of take a look around the
horn is there anything else let's go
back to the a group because we do have a
result that's all we got yes I yeah one
result for now one win and we did
Gujarati finish the game in a draw all
right so that's the that's the final
position with opposite colored Bishops
and stuff and I presume and yeah that
that's correct that's uh what I've
called here is that the Wesley saw
Wesley saw line E4 accomplishes yeah
they've seen us now yeah two or three
times now so it was played in the b in
the big group in mikelian's game right I
guess
so Bishop 26 sculptures Bishop G5 Knight
to C6 Bishop C4 King E7 so yesterday
uh yesterday White Castle long first and
then went Bishop C4 to which black
replied with Knight E5 Now you kind of
have to guard it Knight E4 King F7
Bishop F6 G F6
all right and you get this kind of
position with uh opposite colored
Bishops white being more active but not
perhaps not that
scary for black well I don't know it
looks a little yeah well it is
yeah it is a pawn but apparently
everything's yeah computer is not not
impressed I get it but when you're
sitting there I mean if you know it I
guess it's not scary but
uh yeah yeah why why doesn't even
doesn't even attempt to play something
like F3 who knows anyway so he goes C7
Bishop this might even still be a theory
it might as well be yeah rookie eight
King D2 rookie seven and they've just
basically agreed the draw as soon as
they've reached move 30. sure all right
so that was it
so yeah I mean both sides I guess
showing kind of a lot of understanding
though of the position that has to be
said as well uh so those that takes care
of all the games that have actually
finished what do we still have going on
uh chat was uh screaming and asking for
ilya's game
let's see let's see what goes on here
I well I can see equal material for now
at least
in Ilia just to remind everybody is
somebody that you can find regularly
playing the people here on our streams
so if you would like to see him play
make sure you're following us on Twitch
all right so that's another bedroom we
were talking about but this time very
normal yeah it's kind of main line and
moreover the one that happened in the
match between Carson and nepo I believe
that that was yeah like a very long
sharp line that we are about to see
Queen B3 and queen to D7 C5 Bishop C7
Knights I don't know G3 and now we've
lost Carson yeah where was ah so that's
the deviation I believe Queen C7 steel
and C5 is a different move so I think
Carson was kind of capturing on D5 or
going Knight C3 I don't quite remember
maybe mistakes and yeah anyway so C5
and Bishop to C7 you do not win the pawn
by taking on B7 because Bishop H2 very
nice uh yeah but I'll play
well we in fact attacks the pawn yeah
Knight C3 Knight takes trades on F5
Knight H4 is the temple going back to C8
B C3 okay
um
Knight A6 Bishop G5
so this is where this is where we stand
Rook to E7 okay
Queen F5 yeah and they always find a way
to trade those Queens off yeah so good
at trading the Queens that's what I
wanted to mention that the a group plays
somehow they are very good at finding
you know the way to trade the pieces
Rook 8 what's rookie eight wow that's
deep that's deep I mean the Knight kind
of got stuck right yeah it was yeah
that's
that's gonna get B6 always or something
it would be one B6 that's exactly what
happened yeah it would be one B6
but yeah but the light is
yeah exactly so twitch chat has it I
wanted to tell that Rook Aiden
especially if he's allowed to play
Knight B8 I'd say yeah our Good Old
Coach would say I mean yeah you do not
play like this unless you're preparing
for the next game yeah
resigned this one yeah
uh okay it's a 97 it's almost forces the
night to go back yeah
but then how do you get rid of this
night then right
no no
dude yeah but other than that how do you
uh take on C5 I guess
[Music]
and strangely these are the double pawns
notoriously weak they are supposed to be
but how do you attack them and actually
this trade allows white to have group B7
allows white potentially to have Bishop
D4 unless some silly tactic like Rook B8
and then it's really hard to say what's
going on
because even in this end game
I mean the end game with white trades he
probably shouldn't sure yeah he could
move the rock somewhere can I move the
Rook somewhere one of these somewheres
could be B3 sure Perfect Right sure like
Rook B3 you want to trade trade okay
just whenever you get a position though
with the Knight on B8 you want that Rook
stuck in the corner yeah but but yeah
you can imagine that that it's not fun
to play right I mean it's still some
Knight C8 and white coming to you from
the every single angle yeah 98 is
actually a funny move because if you go
say A6 uh Knight on E7 could have been
bothered with sure but what if I put it
on A7
it's kind of does mean sort of nothing
but but
easily evicted from myself yeah a lot of
weird so something like this yeah so the
feeling is that black is in trouble I
don't know how much in trouble he is
it's move what move 26 for idiot to play
and he is under pressure for sure I mean
once again I'm not sure what's the the
real evaluation of this but it looks
looks like white is getting somewhere do
we actually have any positions with
screens on the board please well let's
have a look around and see what else is
going with Ganguly okay this is serious
this is serious all right so a lot of a
lot of uh stuff will last move being
Queen oh wow
you know what when I've seen this
position I almost got excited because I
I thought that is
never planning to I mean around exactly
in the opposite direction I think we
could find it we found it oh okay
so here we are talking the real Lopez
all right Spanish I haven't had a lot of
real Lopez's for yeah mostly Italian
yeah that's interesting that mostly
people play Bishop C4 nowadays or Bishop
B5 so Bishop to C5 C3 D6 and that's I'm
always confusing the names of this one
so it's not their candles it's uh on the
catch-off variation your tie if
something yeah
and he will hook us up they'll let us
know yeah chat has a few names for this
line I'm I'm sure Bishop to G4 D takes D
takes Queen E2 Knight A5 that that's
sort of a
a bit of a monk white attempt I want to
say because white could have done
something sharper anyway Bishop F3
Knight C4 possibly I've seen this one
Queen to eat two okay
a force and nobody cares about the B2
Pawn
because perhaps this night's gonna get
to get getting stuck there right yeah
the light's getting stuck here so black
just goes C6 B3 now back to B6 and then
the Knight is somewhat misplaced
restricted was white pawns yes and maybe
white hopes to
get some sort of an advantage on the
other hand the bishopon C2 is not
impressive as well
it's fairly typical though I guess for
the Roy Lopez player do they to Roy
Lopez players mind this bishop no not at
all and interestingly like the feeling
is like it's always a stupid piece sure
which you preserve from being exchanged
with like five moves yeah sure ab5 A4 B3
sometimes then only then C2 but whenever
it comes to life but yeah right I mean
that's the feeling you know what's
unfair you know they talk about the
French bishop and everybody you know
really Rags on it what's what about the
Lopez Bishop it's a Triumph absolutely
people have of it yeah okay so ba4ba 4
Rook f2b it's a black uh gets the open
file for himself the B file going to G5
Rook A7 because White had some nasty
threats of capturing D7 Knight would be
Knight would be pinned right so that's
why we're okay seven Knight H4 once
again yeah using pins and double attacks
basically that's what chess tactics is
today's Sunday so I know you were
teaching kids today you might have
taught a couple of these absolutely so
King goes to the Fate Rook D6 Rook to B2
and to my surprise yeah Queen C1 happens
uh yeah but maybe you don't have all
that many other options if you're let's
say direct approach of say going here
doesn't really work then you can't
really move the bishop
you have to protect it yeah you're going
to see one at least and move with the
temple what's the issue with Bishop D3
uh The Rook on D6 right says Rook sarc
ah yeah they kind of lose the connection
and also like Bishop B1 it's not that
attractive uh on many
on many levels but first and foremost
yeah like Rook takes B1 or even perhaps
even flashier would be flashier to take
on D6 yeah yeah
so that's why safe and sound Queen C1
cover the back rank uh protect the
bishop attack the rook and also c66
hanging
might be that's why it's getting
somewhere okay that's one of those
positions where
it optically looks very good for white
but if you don't mind I'll press this
little button she's gonna cheat yeah
[Music]
I would expect it to be better or more
better for white I mean more advantage
that computer actually shows up 0.2 0.3
zero point something like various minor
yeah for white all right
and what move are they on because again
they don't get time until they move
forward he moved 27.
Ganguly is somewhat sure on time with uh
while he had
for some reason the time display ah yeah
okay it's back
it's eight minutes for Ganguly 24 for
now for akobian
and uh yeah let's go back to Hans Neiman
yeah we got a couple of requests in the
chat looks like ah I wanted to say
they've simplified but they've taken it
even further this simplification yeah
they're repeating
okay
oh yeah because that's perhaps uh oh
wait a second I wanted to say I know
what's the reason for them repeating
moves uh that's the reason right takes
here takes here takes here takes here
and I've calculated all the way to Rook
A4 and I thought wide spawn knob but
then Rook 8 happens that's a pin and who
knows I mean maybe White's already in
trouble so it's better why it's better
off not to capture on A4 and therefore
perhaps the whole the whole idea of
exchanging on C4 is so are we just at
risk here that they might yeah they
might just repeat right here very near
to the end of this game let me try to
calculate it kind of count it carefully
Bishop c395 that's the first time this
position is the board okay or rather
after Bishop C3 that's the first time
this position on the board there's one
by D5 Bishop A5 Knight C4 Bishop C3 so
that's two Knight E5 Bishop A5 94 so
White Castle Play Bishop City or rather
write down Bishop C3 and claim a draw
yes absolutely if he wants that is the
correct way to do it you write your move
down you find the Arbiter you pause your
clock you find the Arbiter and you would
make the claim so possibly we're looking
at a draw here and I know the Ilya nijna
game was also very near to its
conclusion I think Ilia was a little bit
worse but possibly able to hold on to
that one let's see if anything oh that's
happened no that that one is still uh
that that's the one with the silly night
on BH right in this game I'm not sure if
it's
it's like it doesn't look to me like the
quite so
I mean maybe just the best position I
don't know maybe computers computer just
says okay White's winning I just believe
the man in my ear and then he makes it
yeah oh wow now that I've cheated a
little oh it's fine oh it's plus two oh
that's kind of nice
probably me
probably me so Ilya is actually in
serious trouble yeah he is in the
serious trouble no I actually thought
that there should be the way for black
to kind of crawl out of this corner but
if if the evaluation is plus two and I
also picked at the lines a little bit so
Black's next moves are like G6 King G7
so basically just chilling out
restricting walking over too so that
yeah maybe to get to this night but even
like when you attack it with the King
wake and oh sorry white can probably
take the pawn on H6 or something so that
usually means bad news if computer says
that the opposition is bad and at the
same time it suggestion is to wait for
it for the position to get worse yeah so
that usually means that you're in
trouble all right so definitely not
looking good for ilionic yeah and we
have one last game which is theodoro
against the paren and here ah okay so
that's
well what I say it looks pretty good for
a paring but once again it's it's yeah
perhaps some
one has to calculate some lines here
because on material count it's two
Bishops and two pawns against Knight in
The Rook all right so black is exchanged
down for two pawns but two powerful
Bishops and I believe I mean divisions I
mean they they look good yes when I
first listen here and there yeah so in
fact uh that's what white has to do I
mean somehow to act swiftly to try to
maybe come up with some threats at least
trade a pair of Rooks because I'd say if
something like this works for black
I wouldn't be surprised if if white is
just lost because yeah well you don't
even have this check I mean I was
thinking I'm clever Rook C8 King H7 Rook
h8 King G6 no check but probably yeah
there is a better move Bishop takes C8
yeah so if this happens for instance
that might be just a disaster for white
because his King is very very weak like
like black threatens like Bishop D4
Bishop F3 in some order
yes it looks good for a party in this
one all right and I believe we've
actually just had two big results the
Hans and even game actually did end in a
draw we could real quick just make sure
they repeated there it is
in a row for Hans Neiman uh and I
believe we may have a result in another
game in the big group
this is let's look at the ox shot game I
believe maybe he has just scored a major
win uh in the B group yes we do have a
result so mikhailan lost with black all
right so we haven't seen this one so we
can just start we haven't seen big group
uh also yeah ultimately
uh Italian are we gonna get another
gioko piano yes yes with some
transpositions so well
um so upset that nobody's interested
playing all those 9g fives nowadays
every Club player wants to see Knight G5
the 38 Bishop C5 C3 castles Bishop G5
that's something that Cambridge would
have done
yeah I think it's exactly his game okay
again so they're following against
possibly McAllen oh from round one 92 D6
A4 G3 oh well G3 is a funny move that is
funny because there's always G5 yeah it
looks like it's there is G5 but I
suspect G5 Knight G5 and wave
attacks yeah like if you if you think
the G file take this guy maybe just G
takes H and and Rook G1 is Unstoppable
right yeah among other things because
it's just one of those ranking moves to
see though but maybe it all works out
yeah anyway black decided not to play G5
Knight F6 back then then whites Bishop
is kind of in dangerous
he does trade on F6 Bishop F6 H4
very straightforward
97 Knight to H2 D5 just keeps it here
Queen F3 Castle short yeah well when I
said he's very straightforward to be
honest and knowing that he won quite
quick I was I was expecting some G4 G5
Stars yeah just some sort of attack but
no not really castles and so far things
fine for black F to D1 Knight to F1 yes
that's purely positional play and D4
wasn't it wasn't that good
D4 wasn't that good because it turns out
white girls Queen H5 and it's really
awkward to protect this guy
Knight G6 obviously runs into Queen G6
and the F7 forms right that that'd be
the most comfortable move like sure okay
you want to get this Knight left from
you can't do it left from C6 so probably
you are going to G6 but you can't now so
Queen E8 Knight F3
trade here King H7 Queen F7 what was
King H7 King H7 it actually sounds like
like a terrible blunder yeah so I'm not
even sure what uh does that mean it just
voluntarily gives up a pie yeah possibly
no he wasn't even in a Time trouble yeah
so he just gave the opponent for for
good 93 B5 and later on okay I mean
White's porn up I guess is this
desperation or what is it that bad
already or I don't understand
no no it wasn't it wasn't
it was in fact well okay DC3 wasn't that
great D takes E3 wasn't that great but
okay paid with King H7 was just a
terrible idea
for whatever reason yeah okay white was
perhaps kind of threatening to take on
E5 which you can hardly stop okay but
yeah but not this point not the F7 Pawn
because this happened to be an easy
really easy task to convert this one
okay but at the moment that it's one
Pawn there's a reminder the computer
says it's plus four so that that's a lot
losing more material simply King to E4 I
mean and all the all the pleasant moves
you can play with what four and and yeah
it's interesting and very often I mean
it's it's peculiar situation that we
teach the beginners once again Rooks to
the open files do not rush when you're
converting the advantage of stuff like
that and usually if you can do it
yourself in a game right or not say high
level that means that your opponent was
playing badly because
yeah you do not really have the luxury
of like say centralizing slowly right
usually yeah yeah usually it's a mess
it's a mess you have to calculate some
precise lines otherwise he'll Escape
absolutely and here like if white plays
all the comfortable moves that probably
means that yeah black done something
wrong and it was proven quite fast
wonderful so congratulations to akshat
Chandra we are hoping to get an
interview with him if we do have it we
will bring it to you but until then uh
we can continue taking a look around and
seeing what else is going on yeah what's
going on in the B group at least it's
kind of to update on the current
positions there so uh lead the round
knock has made the draw right then we
have
um
he is followed by Christopher Yu yes
let's see what Chris is doing oh
okay so it was this could be a fun one a
funny a funny opening sequence and okay
he he kind of has his own opening ideas
that's nice it's nice when someone has a
little bit different style
and the trick is 92. the trick is 92. I
mean it does make some I don't even
remember what's the point But You're
Gonna Play It Again
sell me on Knight D2 against the Knight
of guys you play it against the Knight
of guys and for some reason the belief
is that they can't really play the
Knight of okay at least that's what I've
heard uh so this is for instance already
not a night of that Richter Rouser right
there perhaps this can get fun which
perhaps
um Christopher was fine playing
this definitely has a lot of potential
here yeah like Bishop B5 is not the
theoretical move at least not not for me
okay uh said Miro to discover that Geary
kamski Matlock
a few times and a few other people
disagree with me okay this is a
theoretical move but not the main line
yeah okay so Queen D2 is still much more
popular but Bishop B5 exists yes a queen
to D3 as that that's the point okay he
wants the queen on D3
castles H6 special page four Castle
Stakes on C6 and Knight B3 so just like
okay get rid of the bishop let your
opponent to build strong Center I mean
that's that's how that's how you play
chess and turns out it's not a bad idea
perhaps because
uh strangely yeah I've been a victim of
uh such illusions that black has a
strong Center I did play Rick DeRozan
myself strangely you would prefer to
have the C file low Point yeah that's
more yeah strangely like the B file does
not generate you enough content play I
mean at least in this in this kind of
structures so E5 Bishop F6 and in order
not to drop it it's also kind of very
concrete right because sure dcx porn
what do you do about it
uh you could try 98 but it exchanges the
Bishops the knights ugly only eight so
you don't want to do it
uh G5 is not a move right
tabs is the most sane of all the
attempts but then I reckon E5 and still
put one items again yeah like Knight G4
perhaps just doesn't work or does it oh
well it actually could now that I'm
thinking so my original idea was to
declare yeah probably it is very very
clever Queen G3 almost missed screen G5
but F4 is there yeah okay
so this one also doesn't work
and white is threatening to take and to
take or force you to take with the
g-pawn so that's what happened all right
Christopher Hammer is not that impressed
it seems he has two Bishops ever heard
of Rook B8 sacrifices the pawn queen
yeah okay so now he does have some come
to play on the B file simply because the
Knight on B3 which yeah used to Shield
to block the king now he's gone Rook to
B4 Rook F2 B8 but still White's upper
Pawn uh White potentially like like if
you trade pieces of course yeah that'd
be close to a winning end game with the
Knight on A4 against the bishop even
with even number of Pawns rookie one
Rooker force a basically black place for
for you know for Initiative for counter
play and
okay check traded Rook D1 Bishop B6 so
Bishop comes to life perhaps here and
eventually might end up yeah D4 Queen H3
King E7 that's what we have all right
so you like the pawn here I mean I'm
seeing some dark squares I think it's I
feel like I'd be really scared uh yeah
could be because King on E7 so once
again the stuff that I've learned from
playing the Richter router there are bad
things and good things about little
Exposition so King on E7 in fact very
often is extremely safe
very often it is extremely safe
and yeah yeah I'm not sure I mean I'm
not sure what I'm playing because F2 is
hanging
now um honestly not so sure about all
this queen H3 thing
yeah because like taking on age six that
is not a lot yeah Rook D3 is what he
does but then I have to say Rook takes
F2 how about back rank
absolutely probably that I don't know I
wanted to say that's the plan but it
cannot be the plan it's a check from E1
and then the night is gone
so Rook F2 dragons Rook F1 could this be
that whites just like really low on time
or something yeah we don't see the times
eight yeah eight minutes each you know
all right so but your name is equal
and what move are they on in this one uh
that's Bill 26. all right so they got to
make 14 moves yeah this uh with seven
minutes yeah if not finish it then
clarifies for sure deal with 40 like
someone's gonna be winning all right so
this one has quite a lot of Promise
Christopher you down a pond but
potentially a very strong attack this
one is definitely one to keep on the
radar
uh all right I just figured that perhaps
why he's not kind of snapping this phone
immediately that E4 despite ugly might
be a very interesting alternative
because I don't know whether you where
the Rook goes like if you go back even
some stuff like E3 you know hey yeah
probably okay I'll probably still take
on F2 I mean E4 is too committal of a
move
but yeah sure yes it'll be very
interesting to see what Christopher
comes up with here and what what else do
we have uh we have landamon landamon
against harukunyan and Alexander London
loves them and games he's so far been
shown that he's pretty good at him so
let's see yeah he has one with Bishop
against the Knight right and now it's
the opposite Knight against the bishop
this time he's a pawn down but the
structure suggests that it's white steal
her place for a for a win I would expect
even not sure though yeah if the king
style starts running away not
immediately but at some point not King
G6 mirror The Bishop's hanging
so but this game reached 40. all right
yes per year so that gives us plenty of
time yeah can we just see how they got
here with Alex you can't really can't
really expect to finish the game before
move 70 or something sure uh yeah I
would
like to look at this but we still have
one more game which potentially is your
attention
against uh perfect Brendan Jacobson
so here it's moved 23 only so that's why
I'm interested because yeah this is two
minutes so both of those guys they are
very often like in a Time trouble by
move 20 yes we got two time travel
addicts so this one move 23
uh which is yeah like an end game
straight from the opening and and yeah
and the opening itself is is funny it's
a basically Jacobson says well I ignore
the opening I'll just play yeah that was
called modern modern defense if you're
not mistaken yeah Knight to F6 castles
Bishop H6 C5 well it also kind of plays
it straight forward trades here trades
here they found it the queen trade there
goes E5 goes E6 but but yeah but okay
this is kind of addressing yeah F takes
in castles long also pins
ties down black species Knight to C6
Knight G5 and makes it awkward for black
to dark E6 pawn bishop C4 is a white
apparently wins the pawn back just like
this B5 Bishop to B5 yes and then two
two many things hanging
Knight b6.
it's coming any second now yeah okay so
now the material is equal white felt
like white was much more active but now
look I mean The Rook can if needed can
come back to the game it's the Knight
perhaps which is the problem
uh well Knight F7 rookie 3 is already on
the board well maybe the Knight is not
such a problem after all Knight D6 to F5
yeah it's complicated complicated it's
balanced I believe
must be balanced but yeah
why it's very low on time
so the only game that we actually do
have the Queens is Christopher used game
all right that's I mean that's
definitely one to keep an eye on as we
kind of go through yes this one has the
most potential for some really brutal
attack he yeah shall we switch to the a
group again let's check it out to find
out what goes on apart from this drawing
Neiman's game so so far in the a group 2
draws Hans Neiman with black against
Ninja tomassov and one win against vidit
Sanders Gujarati and we are worried for
what has happened in this one uh yeah
let's see so yes after after he started
to prepare like this Knight B8 thing
yeah white one should be one targeted
the pawn B6 97. yeah he couldn't find
anything better but together and that
this is sad rookie one king H7 Kim G2 G6
yeah well but he plays like a machine
yeah age five if they play all the best
moves they kind of win yeah G4 four
interesting I'm not sure if it's like
the best but that's very
you know well it has its point in a way
right that the black stuck with all this
stuff on the queen side so why don't you
try to attack even with the such thing
it's such a cool idea though yeah with
such a breakthrough it's really nice
such a limited uh material you have like
the five King to G6 Knight G3
and um well Ilya goes with F6 what's
what's F6 for
ah yeah so he he wants to play Same
Knight D7 but then white apparently goes
with a check
and the check and forces the king here
and then it's like something yeah
okay so that's still quite annoying yeah
if you have to play F6 it is it doesn't
feel very good he
um F6 is is an annoying move all right
so but what's the plan now ah 97 anyway
like I was thinking Rook h8 to pin black
down now 97 still kind of fights there
he could it be no
C4 I mean if you try some like
speculating on this um
D5 okay that was the three positions but
it obviously doesn't work they're trying
to win all the awards breakthrough
Awards there should be something yeah
it's just that I mean to highlight what
what's the point of me getting rid of
the c-born I mean it shouldn't work but
the idea is still there
the idea is still there I mean it is
upon up though if there's you got to
find something here with yeah Andrew
White's doing great but
yeah got to be kind of precise here with
how you continue wow
um
I had to double check myself so that
I've
I do count them correctly because I
actually thought the materials equal so
alien's good he's having fun a check in
Knight F5 to fall this could be
something but once again since he played
F6 he probably calculated I'm sure it's
like I'm at least not lost for
yeah for the next few minutes maybe
still Knight D7 it does look scary I
agree yeah let me check my kingy's six
yeah like yeah perhaps it's just lost
right and I
she's seven yeah you actually go back
man I don't know yeah definitely hard to
work he's still he's still fighting yeah
he's still fighting
so and yeah and anything can still
happen here in this one so this is
obviously one that has our attention as
well to see what happens here
right well Chad said but I'm sorry to
remain with this game because actually
he says King G7 and this is much more
precise because yeah it is awkward but
you have to go to G8 not to let the Rook
on the seventh ring and I don't know I
mean it still wins the pawn yeah okay
we'll see usually chat is much stronger
than the very good I mean yes yeah the
kind of collects so many more of them
than us Collective IQ of 9000 yeah is a
known meme
uh yeah so that that's it oparion just
quickly will check Theodore and the
party and see what goes on here the
Bishops or a rook this one was also
interesting yeah because the two Bishops
were very scary but and that's one of
the few when we where we didn't check
you know the position from the start but
now theodoro having one minute I'm not
sure if we have the luxury of sure yeah
we'll hopefully get a couple moves here
pretty quick but uh yeah so what exactly
has happened what he was doing he went
Knight D6 and then Opera interestingly
he went with the bishop D4 first
and after King F1 he goes okay fade all
right
Target is the night night goes back but
then
why did you give a check
now you can't really go to detail well
you couldn't be able to wouldn't be able
to go to D2 anyway you write Knight
controls it now Bishop F3 perhaps yeah
he looks like bad or even yeah maybe
maybe just push the guy yeah
F5 also looks very possible yeah because
yeah like seventh rank was with such a
bishop you're you don't really yeah
you're not scared that you're scared as
you would maybe otherwise
all right I mean a lot of lot of
possibilities yeah with one minute this
is very tough to kind of work out
everything here
yes if operin kind of takes a practical
approach he probably stops here like
calculates a few moves in advance and it
goes with the sequence ah so this is
this is your strategy I'll move and then
I move again yeah because like when
you're on like on Real Time trouble one
minute so you probably
first things first you try to this kind
of
attach each of your next moves to the
move the opponent makes absolutely he'll
play say a five I'll quickly go with
Knight F2 right he'll play rookie eight
I'll okay rookie one Whatever which is a
terrible yeah and then imagine the
sequence goes like I play you play I
play again and then put together a lot
of pressure yeah yeah it's kind of an
interesting psychology because I know
for a lot of players it's like you see
your opponent is on one minute you want
to Blitz all of your moves all right but
as someone that's been on the opposite
side it always feels like the longer
they think the more kind of torturous it
is
yeah like is he calculating some sort of
force Checkmate or something uh well
black didn't play this silly S5 he
actually went with Rook D5 okay so he
wants this route to attack along the
fifth Rank and he says I don't care
about the back rank because King H7 is
available and Rook very conveniently
guards the G5 squares okay it won't be
won't be any checks all right so now's
the moment 30 seconds for Nicholas
and usually that's the moment where you
actually do silly stuff because you
still can't calculate it all right you
do have a check available which I would
bet improves Black's position right
because you had a rook on the seventh
Rank and now you have it on rates and
the King kind of gets closer to the
action and black is perhaps never in
danger with this King but it's so easy
to give this check I mean just because I
need one move closer to the time what
move are we on now uh 32 here 32. we
actually did more gives to go he did not
give this check he went Knight F2 I
suspect the whole idea is that black
girls
uh yeah Black's idea that is the black
can pin this night and
so I guess you actually do have
Alternatives not that I'm thinking
because you could try to play could try
to play for technical yeah you know like
give a check and collect like some dudes
that one A2 on H2 but here you can never
be sure I think still like two Bishops
especially with your opponent in the
time trouble you want to keep one yeah
you want him to blunder absolutely if
you want him to blunder The Rook to a
diagonal check it is that's the ultimate
goal for this game
yeah that's the one however yeah as Chad
kind of agrees with me like like you
take over there you give a check you can
take A2 and F7 survives which is
important so white doesn't have this
check and if he doubles Bishop goes to
E6 like in in my line was it the answer
so quite possibly black wins even there
but you know yeah yeah you probably just
want to finish the game in a few moments
all right so we'll see if open is able
to continue putting pressure on his
opponent who is in time trouble yeah so
we checked nishnik we checked your door
in a pouring and hakuban with Ganguly Ah
that's the one with the Queens on the
board that's a good one Queen to C1 and
yeah we've seen it briefly and then left
somewhere else right so Rook to B7
uh Rook takes C6 yeah indeed and well
some some threads here Queen ate three
wait a sec
is he planning to like go to E7 after
the check because
this is a checkmated entry if I've ever
seen one
I mean if King goes to G7 so it's either
block on E8 which is awkward so probably
he was playing King E7 honestly okay we
saw in the Christopher you game that
that was a safe square but this is a
different right so what just played H3 I
suspect yeah like that they've probably
calculated everything but if anything I
would have given a check to be perfectly
honest I would have given a check then I
mean if you want to play H3 play H3 The
Rook perhaps doesn't do much on the
sixth rank I would guess like it's not
that you're planning to take the pawn or
anything Queen H6 Jack show into G5
still feels like white is getting there
sorry so sorry
okay so it was interesting so he's
sacrificing the bishop but yeah David
check went to G5 so now Rook takes C2
Rook takes F6 happened Knight F6 Queen
F6 I presume is like really bad
Queen hates the thread Queen e5's the
threat right or at least oh wait a
second I know what am I saying what what
queen F6 Queen E5 wake up Mira Guinea
five was the checking your faith Queen
B8 was a checkmen he was just yeah
planning to take everything with the
Checker end up with a few points uh
Queen E7 this is a cool trick yeah this
is very nice uh point being I don't know
what's the point and that's why I call
it it's cool because yeah I believe I
believe Huckleberry who came up with
this move
uh is it that good though
yeah no I'm just trying to figure out
what's going on because it could be that
he blundered Queen E7 as the reply at
first place
and then the rook's hanging you can't
really move the Rook away so he might
have been you know kind of bail out
which doesn't look that terrible for a
white anyway yeah King has to take with
King takes it's same thing Queenie five
chicken then
they have to take with the King and some
sort of Knight F3 perhaps with 95 tread
but that's an awkward peanut there you
can actually try to go with Queen G4 and
then take A6 but then black is not that
worried yeah at least I don't see how
wide wins immediately okay so maybe
don't see how you will be continuing
here for a little bit
um yeah like yeah like trees done move
34 five minutes for white three minutes
for black so
yeah just to be sure to be sure yeah
it's in Black's favor and quite heavily
not like up to minus two all right
reminding me myself yeah I was teaching
the kids I said yeah I've said literally
that Rookie's five bones in in the 90s
tree so that like okay the pawn is
probably gone in some variation that
makes it plus two for black right
absolutely so yeah
[Music]
real quick
um they do they kind of did make it till
move 38 so two more moves to play it and
not such terrible 10 trouble and a huge
Improvement that night from V8 returned
back returned back to him he's getting
his stuff out
all right the pawn is gone if we are
perfectly yeah
still maybe maybe alive maybe alive
somehow
the night's still stuck though
and I've seen someone in the chat
mentioning earlier that Knight to H5 was
very strong apparently here after King
G7 the line that we were okay looking at
for some reason like computer really
liked Knight H5 over Knight F5 okay but
what happened in our game yeah still
looks like much better for white do you
think ilya's gonna weasel his way out of
this one like we saw I mean we saw much
earlier that uh it was something yeah or
whatever in the previous game he was
also in trouble at some point yeah he
could I don't I don't know if you
cheated here or not but is it do you
know yeah I'm not I don't want to cheat
don't do it don't do it I want to try to
figure this one out like it feels like
Illy is kind of wiggling his way out of
this one he's up a bond his main problem
the pawn was taken on G4
I'd say yeah yeah I'm not actually
counting him it just feels like he gave
it up yeah yeah yeah all right then
that's once again I I go about this and
I'm never count upon still be honest but
yeah we figured out they were counting
bonuses for noobs he he was upper pawn
and then I just paid attention to the
last
captured so apparently now it has to be
equal right
all right all right so white does and if
things are equal then it's not
necessarily that black is you know
survived yet but yeah yeah I'm sorry
that that's just randomly anyway king of
seven all right it has all draws yes
that's correct yes for Hans Neiman so
far
the U game is Crazy by the way yeah come
on we gotta get back to this Christopher
you game this is where our most action
let me see let me see Ah that's the one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
almost taken Queen H4 a check and Bishop
C5 those dark squares yeah yeah and I
believe white was ready to just snap on
on D4 if Bishop D4 would have been
played so he is trying for me oh Queen
A3 Knight A4 Bishop F2 now
I don't know what kind of end game that
was being but this is not an end game
cartridge captures on C6 and then the
King goes forward and the King goes
forward and yeah but where is it that's
going C2 just win pardon me
yeah it probably does probably does
oh man yeah because if you block with
denied Rook F4 and still The Rook is
gone correct
or
I mean
it's hard you know yeah it's hard
because this for instance all of a
sudden works for white Perfect Right
these are the kinds of positions where
it's really easy one little inaccuracy
your opponent just takes full force over
of the position yeah
like black supposed to be winning right
it's like supposed to be winning Rook
blocking with the Rook yeah then just
take the so the important part is I say
blocks was The Rook Bishop C3 that as
long as there is no Rook on the file
just walk back to G7 and there is like
no connection say there is no F Pawn it
might have been some Queen C8 Queen G4
sometimes there are there's a loose rope
you want to somehow check and win The
Rook there's nothing there but nothing
there yeah the Kings is fairly safe
uh right so he he actually does play
Rook C3 so that means black is winning
he still has to reach the time so this
was played okay
but what does it mean it means uh while
he is getting close he actually equals
in points for you he was coming in on
three points let's go bring him all the
way up to four equals in points we run
outside one even started the day with
three and a half mm-hmm
made a drawer and he made a draw so that
could bring that could bring uh
Christopher all the way up to the lead
in the B group
very interesting
and you love the U interviews this also
is good for you yeah if you're if you're
excited about the interviews absolutely
yeah yeah I'm more than happy
all right so what else is going on what
else is we expect to come back here
is it yeah pardon me something is wrong
with landaban's game because it says uh
his opponent's got like seven seconds
left so these are not exactly accurate
so sometimes you'll see it go to zero
because every single move there is a
little bit of delay between the actual
sensor so he doesn't mean that he
flagged right here but it does mean he's
very low on time yeah but but that's
been 42 so I get it just because they
made it I made it I get it jumped and
said it's basically two possible clock
setups right sure one is like you've
made more 40 sure basically the clock
the the boat counts for you and adds 30
minutes immediately as soon as for these
move behind and the other one and I
actually personally found it much
trickier one yes it definitely is you
are not in full so it's your task you
keep keep discouraging and so on and
when you are flagged it will do one of
the two things it will signal that
you've lost on time or if if 40 moves
are made it will actually add 30 minutes
there's been a lot of mistakes made
right there
right then and then yeah very often
people would make a mistake and move 41
42 just to be sure to be sure right you
always want to make that extra group
just to make sure that you got the time
and a lot of mistakes are made right
there so
that looks like no mistake was made here
all right all right uh well uh is there
something yeah we didn't check
some opening somewhere but by that point
I'm kind of forgetting which one it was
is there anything still going on in the
AC oh yeah asexual let's find out well
everything's going on right so two
drones that we've already had you Young
Yee against niznik that's uh that's the
position where you just played Knight H5
because he's move 40 okay
so still so Ilia still needs to make a
move here but he's got three minutes
yeah okay plenty of time yeah I'm kind
of getting what the why Knight H5 is so
strong because uh Rook G7 you should Pro
you'll probably end up like going to E6
F5 right and then Knight F4 uh you can
go back after say
okay you're not in check sorry something
like that and just one illustrate so
check here king of fade Bishop H6 so you
probably shouldn't play King of it you
should play King he said you can get
immediately but what I mean is something
like this is going to happen tonight
goes to H5 F4 E6
I thought you were going to take the
f-pawn because there's some winning the
corner yeah that's that's even
much stronger in fact the attack rook's
gun yeah beautiful all sorts of tactics
might happen if you go back
yeah so he actually is in trouble indeed
last month to make freely an engine
let's check the other two games uh
Jacobian with Ganguly oh stuff happens
there okay
King E8 that's a very relaxed move I
have to say I'm just going back casually
Knight E5 but okay okay so they are
exercising like in tactics and perhaps
this means this one yeah so that's the
pain
powerful powerful thingy Knight G4 and
H7 H6 and even like overloading the
queen yeah like as many times as
possible yeah that's a that's a nice
play Queen h600 now oh wow
the tricks are not over yet oh wait a
second oh who's tricking her who's
tricking whom and and they're both very
low on time I suspect so that's why like
you find it six you're happy yeah yeah
yeah yeah and they just take it yeah
they just play the move
[Music]
he probably was better off not not
playing now that I'm looking at it yeah
he was better off not playing H6 okay so
capturing here means yeah so this is
white girls with at least you have this
check here
um
and then attacking D7 a check and some
King E6 or where's the where's the safe
Square
yeah maybe King E6 to attack the Knight
and and what's the material a pawn a two
pawns for the exchange
which so dangerous white would white
would have lost the end game of course
because too many you know kind of
separate pawns and pawns on both wings
of the board they usually uh the knights
are not very good and in this case right
so you'd rather prefer the bishop but
why would you like the king is still
weak right black king is still weak it's
still kind of Queens are on the boards
which thing is uh weaker here uh I'd say
blacks because there is Knight G4 and a
check on this diagonal I can play five
okay yeah well perhaps black is not
forced to color lose sure and I'm
hearing that we actually we'll have to
take a quick pause here because we have
some exciting news in the Christopher U
game let's see what happened there yeah
well I know Christopher was on the
attack in that game he just won his game
against Dennis cartridge uh so after
Rook C3 he actually yeah find
finds a brilliant Bishop takes Rook move
and after okay now letting the king run
away with a few checks
yeah the king runs away all right so at
some moment the king does escape Knight
C3
and uh black has won apparently lost on
time didn't lose that time yeah that
doesn't sound right is this the last
move of the game yeah okay so we have
the result we have Knight C3 we're
saying white play Knight C3 and then
resigned
I mean it could be it's not a not a fun
position to play I mean it's a check and
it takes a five King is safe you know a
bunch of
um not a bunch of extra material it's an
exchange but there will be more because
yeah like everything's falling maybe he
just resigned huh all right well
congratulations to Christopher you for
this win it will bring him up to time
for first in the B group so that is huge
news for our tournament results it might
as well have an interview with him right
if we do get that interview which uh we
are working on it will be coming we will
bring it to you as soon as we have it
ready okay over here Jacobian with
Ganguly I've managed to guess uh the
moves up to King E6 okay and that
happens to be move 40 for both okay so
we expect they'll be now we gotta
they'll figure this out from here exhale
a little yeah and see see what's what's
around
and I'm still somewhat worried about
um London one's Anna that's the big
group then I'll check it later the
lender man's position which didn't
change for good half an hour anything
much to ever happen there but yeah the
Ilia game maybe yeah the India game was
interesting to see like H5 Bishop C7 is
what has happened
and yeah okay so he guards the
FourSquare but a check all right I
suspect some naughty stuff like Rook H7
threatening I don't know if it's weapons
no no you're probably probably is not a
big threat
what could be the move here for white I
understand the Knight is still like
terrible yeah the night's still terrible
there is that there is no
straightforward way not not at least the
one that actually seems like you know
you put on a computer it's going to be
like oh yeah you're just getting kind of
crushed here but like where is it in
real life yeah it's not so it's [ __ ]
E6 I mean just to confirm on this one
it's not so much
it's not so much what's that plus 1.5
which is normally that's pretty serious
but yeah if it's not so straightforward
you know it's a huge positional
Advantage but uh I mean if black would
be dropping some material yeah
huh I don't know I still got a lot of
confidence in Ilia
yeah hanging in there
might so we definitely have our eyes
yeah
and what else what else all right so
we're still hanging on we're waiting to
see what happens in the Ilia game
Christopher you of course has won his
game
just kind of cycling around let's see
yeah right Kanto with Jacobson okay yeah
yeah these guys reached move 40 I mean
just
is it some kind of
position for a study right I know what
these random pieces on the board but
what's the task do we yeah
what's going on here and a few moves ago
okay maybe some moves ago it actually
kind of did look relatively normal sure
so how does the king get all the way to
like D4 sandwiched in the middle yeah
well if it feels like these guys they
kind of operate on on different
trajectories they're pieces like yes you
know maybe some different move rules
apply check Knight D4 and yeah it's so
and to me it always it was hard to play
against such kind of players like you
attack his base he kind of counter
attacks something and all the time yeah
all the time I guess means it's a
relatively good strategy that might have
taken away from Knight takes B5 because
you cannot take these are both like this
right the tricky Knights yeah Rook B7
Knight to C3
Knight D4 Knight to a force of white in
fact I could have gotten a lot of extra
material
but yeah okay and beans
negative one is a little bit okay we can
see yeah I think he started to March up
into the bird I kind of lost threat
entirely I'm guessing
Rook B1 Knight
25. okay okay what's going on uh the
point being yeah
planning to go Knight D3 at check win
the night and if you try to guard it
ah drag me five yeah
all right and black just one thing
because white king if you think of it
okay it does have squares but not that
many absolutely it's home
you also have the task of saving your
night yeah yeah so it kind of does work
yeah
no that that's a that's a crazy sharp
position and especially like I've only
move 40 yeah they're playing for maximum
competition uh complications even with
very low yeah so
wow I mean it's I don't know Knight to
D3 is quite a threat for gergely so can
he actually play Knight D3 that'd be the
favorite series question yep yeah well
checkmate's serious threat of Checkmate
in one and simply moving the bishop
doesn't really help because it's a check
for by King D4 yeah black can try to
take the knight at the end of this line
but white is two pawns up right
still might be chances I mean I say you
go to B5
check here taking that we're just we're
swapping take Stakes yeah we give a
check you can get somewhere backwards
and we have to guard the Knight yeah
maybe black still has chances like D2
sure they take the Knight take one of
the pawns back yeah maybe it's not that
hopeful uh not that hopeless
no that hopeless this one
and once again so maybe a while before
we actually get a move in this game but
yeah absolutely but that's the case with
all of the games interestingly
and Lindemann sure it did
update okay but but yeah but they've
they've probably reached a smooth 40
long time ago and now I'm thinking
because they're feeding us with you know
one move in 20 minutes but I mean it
looks like is white making a lot of
progress here weren't the Kings does the
king moved up the board quite a lot here
yeah it's all the same yeah but when we
tuned in I believe we had like the
position with Knight on E3 already like
this one the bishop was hanging so we
are one hour into the show like more
than one hour
the black king went back White's doing
great they've played
hey yeah why does
kind of doing why it's not doing that
bad right it's upon hanging
yeah maybe E5 but but then you probably
don't win right the five of six he'll
trade one more Pawn
but other than that I'm I'm even a
little bit scared maybe for no
particular reason but if the king gets
to D6 it's saying Knights
I don't know I have a feeling that
London man's going to win it simply
because he's Lenderman he plays and
games this is what he he lives for so
this is always treated him very well
we'll see if he has what it takes to
come up with something here and win this
game yeah but that'll be the longest
game of the round almost for sure
and for for the a group
so we do have some development here Rook
G7 King the one we've seen yeah so this
one we've seen that's move 41 but
they've yeah means they've passed the
time control huckabiano is Ganguly
yeah well actually since we are not in
Russia anymore I mean all the time
troubles like uh done uh why don't we
check this game yeah
from the early stage because yeah it
seems to be at least the resulting
position is very interesting right so
operating somewhere has sacrificed an
exchange or something
yet another customer this one's an open
catalog yeah that's a black captures and
goes C5 all right castles there Knight
C6 uh yeah that's a
that's one
interesting option for white like I
wouldn't say very promising but if you
say if you don't play the other lines
like Queen A4 or Knight E5 I believe
it's already almost refuted by now so
Queen A4 is the main alternative so D
takes C5 is so you're saying this is a
very good way for black to play against
the Catalan is that the takeaway yeah
what to be honest whites options are
limited I mean if you get to this
position my assumptions are quite
limited it's Queen A4 or D takes C5 DTX
C5 leads you to an endgame which by the
way you will have to know quite a bit
that's yeah that's uh the line castles
and then white has two moves one of them
was played in the game it's not B three
and the other one uh was used on few
occasions by Boris girlfriend it's to
play the Knight to E1 which looks
ridiculous but first you get the Knight
to D3 which does the same thing bothers
the Bishop from C5 and the other Knight
can go to C4 can sometimes go to E4
okay anyway so this end game still some
people enjoy playing Knight D5 Bishop to
B4
if I'm not mistaken Bishop D2 was
actually two knights three once again I
don't remember a thing
93 Bishop D2 Knight C4 E4 okay E5 all
right okay so you just went in things
are getting serious just went in love it
yeah he takes e takes and apparent says
okay that's a pawn give that to me
that's the pawn yeah Bishop G4 Bishop G5
some tactical fireworks uh and once
again fireworks fireworks is okay but
what if I take
and white captures on D5 sure and there
is at least some at least logic so Rook
is threatened and if Rook B8 I assume
some Knight E5 Knight C6 or what's the
anyway anyway
torrent just kills Bishop G4 okay three
sacrifice and exchange Bishop to F6
Intimates are very important because
otherwise the bishop was hanging
Rook to C1 Bishop takes F3 Bishop G4 H5
and this is how this is how we've gotten
there
yeah we saw from this point yeah it's
very interesting because I still I
thought these like two Bishops they
looked very very scary at some moment
right somehow wide um
sort of not not to fall apart rookie
seven Bishop F3 still black he's in
black is obviously but uh I believe as
long as long as the material stays the
same the Bishops are on the board very
hard to play for white like in a
practical game Rook to E7 and he yeah he
just creates the past Pawn there's the
current position there right that's a
scary Pawn Yeah
it actually walks to B3 to B2 wait what
does white do to stop me how are you
gonna stop me
but it's not easy
yeah is there a way it is
Knight to D2 Still Still
B3 is an option you can make an argument
for like more pins Bishop C3
pushes yeah but B3 might just win
straight up
be dream or just win I'm just pushing
and if anything you'll get the chance to
disturb white from the other angle like
like go H4 at some point yep
feels very promising for grigoria parin
who is on 50 uh he's doing very well
he's then two and a half out of four
plus one already Yes I might as well
uh join join the leaders
or become one of them yeah if he does
win yeah he will catch up to vidit in
the lead for uh once again was held for
a drawing yeah keep keep forgetting
so hakuben and Ganguly need some time to
figure out what what has happened during
the time travel yeah all right well that
white try to figure out what to do here
let's see if he's can figure out any
solutions yeah yeah here it looks like
it's it's a good yeah oh it's actually
it's black to move so he gets the yeah
yeah offering has to decide if it's B3
or not yeah all right I've kind of made
a move for him to be sure okay yeah
all right uh well can I kind of don't
really understand how this chart works
on my lab because I see a lot of a lot
of messages from the YouTube chat yeah
but to reach people and just send us
something in the Twitter are you joking
are you not reading caramel cheesecake
332
saying vampire chicken
streamer slash teacher absolutely but
that's a second that yeah excellent
that's good I'm glad to hear it so uh
glad to have everybody with us we are
here we are watching you guys we're
watching the twitch chat we're watching
the YouTube chat uh we appreciate
everybody that's been here hanging out
with us as we've been going through all
of these games so always a pleasure to
be here always a pleasure to see all of
the very nice people that have been in
the chat so far
and yeah and then my only disappointment
is
never been interviewed is it personal do
you think is he intentionally drawing
all of his games I I take it personally
I'm just saying this is a personal
difference on my person like I'm not
giving interview to these guys I mean
any anywhere else anywhere else yeah so
but anyways obviously if Hans ever does
win a game here we will definitely he
will not get an interview with him we'll
tie him down we'll do whatever we got to
do uh to get that interview say what was
uh there was some game which was kind of
very close to conclusion let's once
again maybe the B group possibly ah no
everything that could conclude in the
big group has already concluded so once
again a reminder that uh Chandra
the final position yeah remember yeah
that says Black's last name was King h8
and resigns at the same time fair enough
uh then yeah Christopher you won against
God Rich we were still
yeah something like that yeah this
all right we do think that we are going
to be getting the Christopher you
interview we are working on it we have
not forgotten uh we are going to bring
it to you as soon as we got it yeah so
and we have two games going one is
letter one game so which if you like
Christopher you they are long he might
still be talking he might maybe it's not
done yet all right all right and then
can't uh
against uh Brandon Jacobson here yeah
why just played Knight D3 that was maybe
like you know not coming to the
conclusion but still a very funny kind
of looking position does this lead to
like the same position I guess like at
least if Rook takes D1 we're going to be
doing the same thing yeah they'll be the
same position but a different kind of
funny way there'll be a Checkmate it's a
black as we figured out
all right or rather he was it was my
imagination What black has to do move
the bishop to to yeah to get here
which one once again might be not the
end of the line uh Bishop B5 and say
white dinner gives a check doesn't give
a check but then moves the night I mean
I think maybe White's better off like
moving the knight from the a yeah it's
very confusing once again and then a
night before is another option way too
many way too many that's one of those
games do you when you personally I guess
it's just a matter of personal
preference do you like these games where
it's for you personally it's complicated
for both sides or other things hey I
used to be honestly I used to be quite
good at such things sure but like
because now let's say at the club when I
was asked like show some of your sure
show your best games best games and I
realized like yeah whenever I'm showing
something it's such a mess right right
even though I did have a reputation of
understanding your thing
positional chess right and also like the
best game it's always a mess like this
but one thing when when you are playing
this you're familiar with patterns like
from early in the game right and then
they are kind of adding up but it's
somewhat easier to navigate compared to
the commentator than we are tuning in
sure and I say like okay eight moves
candidates and then you have to yeah you
know the players are sitting there being
like oh man I wish I was a commentator
right now those guys they can just
blunder pieces nobody cares I think the
grass is always greener on that plane
absolutely no but that's yeah that's
sadly the benefit of coming to the job
sure you can suggest
uh look at it
well not realize that it's dumb be sure
be told by the child
you're right with chat yeah I'm thinking
to move back and let's unlike the other
one so that's a good thing
so definitely would be interesting to
see what they come up with because every
move could also be a surprise that's
very easy to imagine they play something
that we didn't even consider or
something okay so we are left with two
end games in
uh in the big group but yeah while Linda
lend demons is an end game end game
why are you not showing some love for
Lenderman okay this is this guy's a
professional and a game player yeah you
know yeah there's a lot of respect for
this commitments to playing such
incredibly obvious end games so
frequently I believe he does and once
again it's not impossible that he will
win this one uh by like some some tricky
tricks
say King C6 FC E5 sorry I suspect white
might be winning major update we will
have the Christopher you interview in
only three minutes our producers have
been working extremely hard to get us
this one so we know something is good is
coming and uh just hyping you up for
that big Christopher you interview all
right so let's continue with this uh
yeah I'll quickly run away to the a
group all right see what happens here no
moves right literally no move no there
were some B3 was played and King to D1
was played okay all right is it really
it's really like gonna stop that King
who stops the pawn okay so one of the
one of the possible ways again one of
the possible ways after
B 3 I'm sorry B2
he could try to go King C2 and then sack
in exchange back take on B2 okay I'm
almost with you and I maybe have some
chances of surviving okay because like
if the B2 Pawn survives it's better like
you just win with more
uh anyway uh let's see the other games
and for this
week right okay
in the game now King E6 F4 F5
he didn't play a five sorry he he went
through five I don't think we thought
about Rook here
and King F3 and then F5 okay so it
doesn't mean he's holding
doesn't mean I assume not but I believe
Ilya you got it
um yeah well I mean to be perfectly
honest
what white deed like yeah last few moves
either has you know tactical
justification or just purely wrong
because you had a wonderful Bishop you
could have I don't know at least traded
it on F4 and you've played before the
bishop does he have ideas of coming to
another diagonal yeah could be
could be but isn't black just on time
with the ah well maybe that's the point
so Rook F7 and you you kill like
this and when he takes
also whenever you're winning the F5 but
that's like nonsense there like F5 is I
mean you would expect white to win like
half a rogue yeah
yeah and and the other the alternative
is not that impressive either okay King
D7 the Knight is stuck we agree but I'm
around that still so still fighting
so it could actually run away with half
a point Elia
all right don't worry that that you
interview is coming don't worry about it
we are working on it it's old hold your
seat so it is coming uh it's gonna be
big I don't know what's happening but
something big with that new interview
does it I mean it honestly feels like I
mean ilia's hanging in there uh yeah
right so well
I will be
um did they say like before that like
five months behind I said I will be
surprised if white won't find something
now it's the opposite in fact yeah yeah
you won't be surprised I'd be I'd be
surprised if there is like
straightforward way right so well well
now that um it looks to me like yeah
Rook G5 I understand Ruby five night G7
probably white wins the pawn but then we
can actually recall that yeah he still
will have the double pawns and then yeah
the knights the night's still got to get
into the game
a little bit far away but yeah we'll see
all right yeah not very fascinating to
see if you know if black and not
desperate
not uh hopeless yet all right definitely
one that we we can keep coming back to
this is a very good how is Hans doing
for those of you just joining uh if
you've only seen and if you haven't seen
any of the commentary don't worry all
you need to know is that Hans has had
five draws in five games that he's
played in this tournament so far
so he is at two and a half out of five
points right
something's missing still ah Jacobian
with Ganguly these guys didn't stop even
after the time control so well I called
it all right you did same thing but not
the last move honestly okay I mean you
have pieces you have to activate them
centralize yeah even if you can see if
it's your own King I guess I mean he's
anticipating a check and moving that's
the idea I suppose like he's
anticipating a check on F6 with the
queen and he's getting the kids yeah
he's going all the way somewhere around
here funny enough it could be that the
king is safer than anywhere else because
look the Knight on G4 it kind of anchors
white position together it guards E5
right well guard some squares around the
king sure so let's say let's just
imagine yeah
the king's only two or B3 whatever how
do you actually bring the Knight to
attack this game very true not easy
right so I'm not saying yeah he actually
didn't didn't play King C4 immediately
okay but maybe it is yeah the point is
like the king is safer than it might
seem
Queen F6 he wanted B2 though okay so
that means a six can be taken question
mark
because if you know I mean I'm confused
Channel seriously I'm confused I mean uh
check 183 what to do
C5 perhaps because if you go don't worry
I know exactly how to get out of this
Jam Just I know
I know how to just get out of this Jam
we will trick all of the viewers we'll
here's how we get them here's how we get
them this is it we have the Christopher
you interview after all I don't know
what is happening with this one they've
been telling me all about it in my ear
this whole time this one is going to be
huge Christopher you had a big win they
tied him up uh in the B section so let's
go ahead and get his thoughts on his
game today
I'm here again with Christopher you and
he's going to take us through his game
today against uh I think Master uh
Dennis yeah and so I wasn't take control
over one of them I said go for it
so I wanted to surprise him in the
opening so I I played an opening I don't
usually play but also to my surprise he
seemed to be well prepared and he
surprised me right back with this um
Bishop G5 E6 Bishop B5
and this is not really the main line but
it definitely got me confused because I
didn't know the Siri well so it was I
was already pretty uncomfortable but I
decided to just develop my pieces Bishop
D7 Queen D3 Bishop E7 queenside Castle
H6 Bishop H4 castles apparently this is
all still Siri to my surprise but I was
I was just making up the moves
and I didn't really know what the theory
was
he still witched out until Knight B3
and I saw he was threatening E5 so I
kind of had to make the ugly decision to
go E5
and let him play Bishop takes F6 G takes
F6 and now my Pawn structure just looks
terrible
this but I I don't feel like this
position is as bad as it looks despite
my Bishops looking like they're blocked
by their own pawns and my king looks
like it's gonna be checkmated in a few
moves he actually can't really get at my
king because his pieces aren't quite
aiming at it yet
but I still felt I still felt a little
uncomfortable here but after Knight C4
review I decided to go for my own attack
I didn't really see anything else to try
because my position is
positionally it's
horrible but maybe due to my counter
play with my Rooks
and my queen on his King it's not that
bad
Queen A5 so I was just I was just trying
to aim at his King and hopefully one day
or something will happen but I didn't
see what was happening
so it was it was very hopeful thinking
but I didn't see what else to do
so he takes a five Rook before
I still really didn't see any attack but
I thought that at least I'm scaring him
at least I'm at least I'm being annoying
like my peop like
it's it's I don't know I felt like it
was intimidating my Rooks along the B
file even though they're not threatening
anything
at least I thought he might be
confused and I was definitely also very
confused about what was going on and
what the evaluation was
because I didn't really see what to do
for either side so it's like a very
weird cat and mouse type of position
where we're both waiting on each other
to do something when we don't see
anything to do so he was like trying to
get his pieces then we work he won ricka
Ford King B1 King B1 was a nice move
there was a crazy variation with Bishop
B4 94 Bishop takes E1 Knight takes F6
king h8 queen H3
King G7 Knight H5 King H7 Queen G3
and I was like
what the freak I made it here so I can't
go for this
so I went I went for Rook d8 seeing all
of this and I spent like 30 minutes here
burning all my time trying to make
bishop B4 work
and
after I saw that after I saw that it
didn't work I kind of realized I had to
settle down for
a more tame position
Queen G3 King f8
here I I'm thinking he might have been
able to just take a draw with Queen H3
King G7 Queen G3 king f8 queen H3 but he
was ambitious and he played Rook takes
dhek Bishop takes d8
but all of a sudden I kind of realized
that my position might be good because
my Bishop is coming to B6
and his pawns are getting attacked
and it like a few moves ago I thought
that I was I might be completely losing
and all of a sudden I feel like I felt
like I might be winning
so it was a huge dramatic turn of events
in my head like and now I started to
feel really good like I'm gonna win this
game
Rick D1 Bishop B6 Queen H3 now I win
King E7 just to prevent Queen takes H6
with check
and again it's it's like an unfortunate
situation where it's hard for him to
find a good move
this despite my king looking a little
bit weak he can't really do anything
because he doesn't have enough pieces
and some somehow his Pawn structure
looks very weak all of a sudden due to F
F2 falling and F5 being weak
so here I saw him hovering over his
Queen
and I saw he was about to place it on
the D3 square but then he realized that
it would be a horrible wonder and as
soon as he realized he shook his head
like crazily and like he almost was like
what am I thinking like he was like he
had a he had a huge reaction and it was
quite funny to see because he was about
to play Queen D3
4 Queen F3 Queen takes C3
and I I was getting so excited but then
I saw him realize it and I was like okay
but it's still a good position
but I was hoping to get this after Queen
takes C3 Rick takes D1 King B2 Bishop D4
black wins
win H4 I think he played
now I have to use all my remaining brain
cells to remember the rest of the game
because
uh I see that there's like a 30 minute
delay
Queen H4 okay I'm gonna need to recall
okay it was Rick F1 check King B2 Bishop
C5 so now it's threatening mate
so if he goes into like an end game it
should be losing because my Pawn on E5
is really strong
and his Knight on A4 is having trouble
really getting into the game
so instead after Bishop C5 he won Knight
A4 trying to keep the position
complicated
I went here so I was still trying to
trade Queens Queen E4 Queen E1 and now
now it's starting to get funny so he
didn't want to trade Queens of course
because it's just a losing end game so
he wanted to make it complicated so he
was trying to get like a mating Attack
Of Perpetual check something along those
lines
but now now his King starts going
gung-ho you know like he's going to B5
A6 B7 like he was too I saw a look on
his face and he was like maybe I'm back
in this game this is getting interesting
you know
but the problem is after Queen takes C2
Rook C3 which is what happened I can
apparently just take the rook and he
does not have Perpetual check
and at first when I took the Rook I the
look on his face sort of gave me the
sense that he saw the other Perpetual
check and he was like he looked at me
like what are you doing are you allowing
are you giving allowing me to have a
Perpetual check but surprisingly this is
not a Perpetual check because my king
kind of triangulates out of the way
so he kept checking me
and then and then my king escaped
and after Queen C5 King G7
here here he he's stuck he I think he
like smashed the table and screamed
something under his voice and said like
the f word or something
and it was it was it was it was kind of
funny but
um
because it was obviously a bit rough for
him and after point after this move he
didn't even he didn't wait for me to
even make my move he just resigned so
well thank you for sharing it
um we were out here in
I've heard a little bit of the feedback
from the point your opponent yeah
um but no congratulations to you
um they'll put you in the first in first
place right now in your group
um tomorrow you play again so have fun
and then I'll hang out at the club but
see you then thank you thank you
that was Christopher you who now is
sitting uh tied at the top of the
leaderboard with ronik sadwani and I
think the most fascinating thing about
the Christopher Hugh interview he's the
only one that's telling us like this was
the body language this is all my
opponent must be honestly I thought the
scene that he saw that I'm an idiot and
so on and his opponent literally got so
angry he was smashing the table he was
saying swear words uh it's it's
interesting and I guess that's the only
only thing that you can get from a
Christopher you interview so thank you
Christopher for the uh insight and with
that we're actually going to go ahead
and take a look at these standings for
the a group and as you can see uh we
still there's a lot of games that are
still going on but for now we got vidit
at the top of the leaderboard with three
and a half right below that is Von
Nguyen Hans Neiman of course five draws
equals two and a half points we are
still waiting to see what is happening
in the games between ilionic Gregory
o'para and Yu Yang Yi Aram hakobi and
Surya Ganguly Nicholas theodoro but we
do know for sure that nijot abisov is
sitting at two points so a lot is going
to change change between now and
tomorrow and we'll keep you updated as
things change but Miro can you also let
us know what is going on in the B group
yeah in the big group we have three
results currently so Alex land demands
game is pendings those two that are tied
for the first place around Knox advani
draw Wright and Christopher U this is
the big news yeah just analyzed yeah
they can be called top with yeah Alex
Lindemann yeah you can catch them up
with yeah if he wins
other than that yeah Dennis coverage I
understand why he is not happy man he
started with two out of two I know oh
yeah it's gonna pushed back to all the
way to 50 percent uh the other very
entertaining game that is still going on
is giggly counter against Brandon
Jacobson absolutely you have to worry to
see what happens with all of these games
but this is the end of our show for
today we saw some pretty exciting things
a lot of unusual games
we got some weird study-like stuff going
on all sorts of fun things and if you do
want to come back and join us tomorrow
make sure that you follow us we'll be
back at 4pm central time please again uh
make sure that you're safe out there use
the hashtag fall chess classic watch us
live on us chess Champs and until then
we will see you for round six tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited